- In the last year it's been hard
to get together with our friends.
We have to be safe and socially distanced.
That's why we created a new segment called
The Drive-Interview.
♪ Drive interview ♪
(clapping)
(laughter)
Every time.
♪ View ♪
With the shake, with the shoulder (laughs)
The other day I headed
over to the drive-in
to catch up with America's
favorite TV doctor
in his favorite car.
I'm talking about Dr. Phil
everybody, check this out.
(upbeat music)
Hey!
- Hey!
What's up?
- What?
So be honest with me.
This is the weirdest
place you've ever met up
for a therapy session.
- This isn't a therapy session, right?
'Cause this would be in
the running right here.
- Oh no, of course not.
There's no, I don't need therapy
right now at all, Dr. Phil.
No, everything's great.
Everything's lining up just perfectly.
- Not a weird year.
- No.
- Nothing going on?
- This had been a
such a, it's such a,
you know what, I feel light I've yeah.
- Yeah, I have to say
you look very at home
in that big old truck.
- This is,
Hey, this is my truck
for like 15 years now.
This, his name is sunny.
- I would have to say,
you look very at home in that truck.
- Thank, and you look very at home.
What kind of wheels are those?
- This is a 57 Chevy.
- Oh my gosh, it's beautiful.
- Did you name your car?
- The Beast.
- Did you just name it?
- No.
(laughter)
- The beast?
- The beast.
- The beast, I like it.
- This was my dream car
when I was growing up,
but there was no way I could afford it.
So when I got where I could,
that's the story everybody tells, right?
When they get where they can, they do.
- Yeah.
- But this car has an amazing history.
- Really, what?
- Well, I owned it for a while
and then I was gonna put it in the shop.
15 minutes after it went
in the shop on a Sunday,
it was stolen.
- What?
- Gone.
They crashed through the doors, took it.
It was gone for one month,
two months, three months.
And so it was gone for 10 months.
- That's the craziest story.
- And then finally the
Burbank Police called and said
"We think we found your car."
And they arrested the King pin
of this mafia group in town
and an hour and a half later,
his lawyer pulled up in
front of the police station
with this on a trailer.
- This is a movie!
- And it was trashed.
They tried to pick it up with a forklift,
knock holes in the side,
they crushed the fins.
But the insurance company paid
for it and got it back to me.
So, it was gone for 10 months.
Now Robin's afraid to ride in it
'cause she thinks the
mafia is gonna retaliate.
That we wanted the car back.
- You know, that's a
legit concern, Dr. Phil.
- Yeah, I don't know, she's
kinda short, she can duck down.
- Okay, so we're at a drive-in.
Did you grow up doing drive-ins?
- Oh yeah.
Everybody talks about
you used to hide your buddy in the truck.
- My father made my mother
get in the trunk of a car,
so he didn't have to pay, you know?
- That was a thing.
I will say I, have put my
wife in the trunk though.
That's a bad.
- That also sounds like a mafia story.
- Look, I had this Mercedes and it was,
you remember the old 450 Mercedes?
The two-seaters?
- Yeah.
- I had one that I loved
and it had a rattle in it.
- I think I know where this is headed.
- And I asked Robin.
I said, "Okay, look, do me a favor.
Will you get in the trunk?
And I'm just gonna drive
around the cul-de-sac
and listen and see if you can
hear where the rattle is."
And she said, "Get in the trunk?"
I said, "Yeah.
Listen, I'll put something
down you can get in it."
She said, "Oh, God."
So she gets in the trunk,
and I said, "Just kinda hold the lid,
so you can hear where the rattle is."
And as we pulled out, I didn't know.
I hit a little bit of a
bump and the trunk latched.
So now she's locked in the trunk.
- Oh my God.
- So I pull back in
and I walked back there
and the trunk is latched.
And it's just one of those
that you push the button.
I popped the trunk open.
I said, "Did you hear anything?"
Oh, did I hear something!
- Oh my God.
- She came climbing out of there.
- I would have whopped your behind.
- I can't tell you on
daytime television what
sweet Robin had to say.
(laughter)
You got a rattle in your head,
let me tell you something.
Oh my God, it went from bad to worse.
- All right, well wait.
- She never found the rattle.
(laughter)
(rock music)
- Okay, I have a question.
Do you think that it's
unhealthy, you know,
emotionally, mentally to be competitive
with cars and like, you
know, like you wouldn't
you'd probably frown
upon like racing, right?
- I don't know, you got
your pink slip with you?
I assume that yellow is
not a streak up your back
and you're willing to line these up.
- Oh I, you know what?
Sunny is about to take you down, sir.
- Okay, well, let's fire 'em up, sister.
- All right, well, good luck.
If I'll see you at the
drive-in later after you,
after my dust.
- I'll see you in my rear view mirror.
- Whatever.
(truck starter croaking)
Do you you hear that engine?
(engines revving)
Bye!
(audience clapping)
It's always good to catch up with Dr. Phil
and y'all can see Dr. Phil weekdays.
Check your local listings, everybody.